YouTube slam two Torpedoes under our
side cheeks
we were coming up on 700 000 subscribers
when YouTube dropped the bomb the Box
apocalypse Bob
over 600 videos on the Channel all of
them restricted in less than 12 minutes
didn't see the first video get
demonetized for a half hour
an hour-long interview
Jordan Peterson
you know how to tell when your video is
about to be demonetized chief
until by how many misinformation
warnings to see by how much truth
is actually in there
they didn't know
because YouTube's policy has been so
secrets
no email notifications had been sent
they didn't answer any of our emails for
weeks
if that fellow conservatives would help
join the fight
their first week chief
business big con started screwing so he
farmed out so you know into a tight
group mug Club
you know it's kind of like the old
squares in the battle like you see in
the calendar like the Battle of Waterloo
and the idea was
big Tech come along with big con coming
to take control of our channels and we'd
start to pounding and hollering
sometimes big Tech and big cotton go
away
and they wouldn't
sometimes big conservative comment they
live right in you right into your eyes
you know the thing about a big cons is
they got life as high black eyes
they come at you doesn't seem to be
living
Julia hear them inside tired Rhino
talking points those milk toes spineless
eyes over White
oh then you get that terrible bullcrap
season with this letter
your channel turns red from a hard
strike spite of all the fighting and the
hollering the supposed allies coming
with YouTube themselves
repeated pieces
[Music]
nobody said a thing when my club moved
on Lost access to all our subscribers I
don't know how many mud clevers maybe
four hundred thousand don't know how
many unshipped mugs we got emails every
hour
on Thursday morning Chief I get a letter
from a so-called friend of mine
one of those big conservative networks
big money type
and I see the contract offered scrolled
up and down
kind of a mistake
um
turns out it wasn't
I know when the contracts came in Chief
exactly
bastards were forced to sign literally
110 penalties against their own
conservative content creators they have
a big Tech
that was the time
most frightened
seeing that so many people on our side
and dead
big Tech themselves
I'll never be part of one of those
networks again
so
bidding war started with everyone mining
a pound of Flesh instead we decided to
go dark until
March 20th 2023.
anyway
we kept the Mud Club
[Music]
so no matter what the Market's doing
he's ready
[Music]
you know
foreign
[Music]
let's go
downstairs
[Music]
just
remind me
[Music]
I wish myself
[Applause]
[Music]
in the dancers
foreign
[Music]
YouTube slam two Torpedoes into our side
cheeks
we were coming up on 700 000 subscribers
when YouTube dropped the bomb the Vox
apocalypse
over 600 videos on the Channel all of
them restricted in less than 12 minutes
didn't see the first video get
demonetized for a half hour
an hour long interview
Jordan Peterson
you know how to tell when your video is
about to be demonetized chief
tell by how many misinformation warnings
to see by how much truth
is actually in there
they didn't know
because YouTube's policy has been so
secrets
no email notifications had been sent
I didn't answer any of our emails for
weeks
I thought fellow conservatives would
help join the fight
that first week chief
business big con started screwing sorry
Farm now so you know into a tight group
mug Club
you know it's kind of like the old
squares in the battle like you see in
the calendar like the Battle of Waterloo
and the idea was
big Tech come along with big con coming
to take control of our channels and we'd
start to pounding and hollering
sometimes big Tech and big cotton go
away
and they wouldn't
big conservative Convent they look right
in you right into your eye
you know the thing about a big Kansai is
they got life
with black eyes
they come at you doesn't seem to be
living
Julia hear them inside tired Rhino
talking points those milk toes spineless
eyes over White
oh then you get that terrible bullcrap
season with this letter
your channel turns red from a hard
strike
supposed allies coming with YouTube
themselves
repeated pieces
foreign
moved on Lost access to all our
subscribers I don't know how many mud
clevers maybe 400 000. don't know how
many unshipped mugs we got emails every
hour
on Thursday morning Chief I get a letter
from a so-called friend of mine
one of those big conservative networks
big money type
and I see the contract offered scrolled
up and down
kind of a mistake
turns out it wasn't
I know when the contracts came in Chief
exactly what the other poor bastard were
forced to sign literally 110 penalties
against their own conservative content
creators and they have a big deck
that was the time
most frightened
seeing that so many people on our side
that
big Tech themselves
I'll never be part of one of those
networks again
so
bidding lawyers started with everyone
mining a pound of Flesh instead we
decided to go dark until
March 20th 2023
.
anyway
we kept the Mud Club
[Music]
[Applause]
would I know
[Music]
that's called a slightly frustrated sip
it's a good problem to have
yeah
but it's a problem we were we were more
than on time if Alex Jones of course is
who's here was on time and this I mean
it's a miracle
but Rumble uh we appreciate again
servers crash because so many of you are
migrating from YouTube to rumble they're
moving at Warped speed you know but it
needs to be warped or Rumble is that a
speed I don't know I guess it's plaid uh
so please if you right now wherever you
are on social or if you're on YouTube
Michael Jordan just let everyone know
comment on social uh post it out there
let people know that we are on we
apologize for the delay uh so many of
you tuned in that it crashed and that's
not going to be happening again right
number two Gerald right how are you sir
I'm good good
um fantastic all right it's a good
problem to have yes it's a good problem
190 200 000 people trying to do it at
once yeah no I mean I've been in Joe
Rogan Studio back when we were breaking
records as a guest then we get very
excited about 150 100 670. that's Elon
Musk level live at one time that means
you know those shows will get 20 30
million views total uh so
congratulations to you and to rumble but
like you were saying off here nobody's
got the servers like YouTube yet but
rumble's building him so this is Growing
Pains yeah no it's growing pains it's a
good problem to have and I don't want
you married to your phone today because
you don't need to be dealing with all
this crap no phone all right so we have
so much to get to so I appreciate it my
question actually of the day to you
before we get into anything else here
today is how do you watch the show
because we don't really have the ability
to do Nielsen which is largely fake uh
but send us your pictures you can send
them to me on social whether it's
Instagram whether it's Twitter uh at s
Crowder at louder with crowd I believe
on Instagram do you watch on your
television how many people are watching
we're trying to get an idea for how many
people per screen because I know it's
like two and a half three million of you
whatever it is but we don't know how
many people are watching that screen let
us know and uh that'll help us kind of
get an unofficial head count let's use
10 as the multiple let's just do that
ten that's probably high oh my thing my
headphones are a little bit low and
yours a little bit High all right so
we're going to be talking today Donald
Trump update and as this breaks live
regarding the indictment we'll be
discussing that uh we'll also be
discussing you know Donald Trump versus
Ron DeSantis this sort of fracturing is
taking place
what the pros and cons for each of them
I don't know if you notice there's a
major seaweed blob we're headed on a
collision course here in the United
States and uh I don't know if you saw
some racism that took place in the New
York subway well it's Wednesday really
and uh we'll also be talking about the
YouTube Exodus that is taking place it's
very and I mean for the very first time
the numbers have flipped YouTube is
becoming the backup
provide it Rumble make sure the servers
are strong enough we love you but come
on what are you doing what are you doing
there in Florida get off the beach
red Tide's great red tide well that's
why they're on the beach well it's red
tide for servers right none of them
number two Gerald CEO now how's it feel
I'm doing well sir how are you I'm good
I'm just a little jumbled because we're
trying to get stuff by the way Gerald's
lighting is very nice and so is yours
and I'm not that beautiful person but
why do I have the flashlight under the
face over the head look well that's
because we have a segment series
horrible
City keep interrupting I'm going to
knock knock me out folks no that's
that's broke my nose look at it you just
make him go kill everyone above my head
just kill the one about my head what do
you no don't make him go dark then he's
gonna look like he's in the bottom of a
pizza parlor with podesta pizza no turn
those lights on this one off the one in
the back okay
uh do not tune into while we're still on
YouTube mad
maxworld.tv at noon Eastern uh 11
Central he will not be hosting a show
there nope and that link is not
available for you to peruse it will so
Alex Jones how are you sir well I'm good
here it's quite the controversy that I
got so excited yesterday that I got hurt
myself yes yes you did uh should we show
that first I I think that might be a fun
way all right okay so let me just show
you exactly what happened here first
this will be uh uh clipboard so I'm sure
you've all noticed Alex you know you can
show them the the Shiner not really
Shiner but that's pretty good it's
almost an inch long and it popped open
pretty wide yeah
it wipes right off so I'm sure that
you've all seen this and uh you may be
wondering why but luckily our security
cameras here in the office captured the
whole thing and Alex gotta love him he
is what you see is what you get he came
out and he was excited so you can't hear
the audio he's like why don't you guys
tell me you had 175 000 on Rumble that's
Monumental and he's he's we're all like
okay great Alex and then you see him
turn back and he forgets that there's a
wall well somebody said they said hey
you're back on your show right so I go
okay bam right in the corner of the wall
so let's uh play this here on to a man
you know they say if it bleeds
please ladies and gentlemen and uh I was
literally out there in the hallway
congratulating Stephen Crowder on record
level views and then I said you're back
on air so I turned and they got this
wood paneling on the walls so the edge
of the wall it's okay this nose been
broken like 20 times so it's not a big
deal all right so here's the best part
of that is right away as it's happening
as he's about to walk into a well he has
a man who is wonderful there to protect
him right there who helps keep Alex safe
and he's watching the whole time and as
soon as it happens he's his face just
says of course and you even looked at
him like are you gonna do something
about this Mike is more than security
super smart good friend of mine he's
also a podcast for his own right uh but
he kind of has to hold my hand he knows
I get distracted and he said he told me
last night but today when I saw the
video it's true he saw it happening a
live time and almost said something but
he didn't and then here we go let's
let's roll this here uh Tim show so
here's Alex walking in okay we know
what's about to happen now right before
that happens Gerald is looking like are
you gonna do something
and Mike right there is just like yep
zero Parts face because you can really
see him smiling and laughing he's
smiling and laughing he's more so
supposed to protect yourself
meets the Tasmanian devil yeah well the
same voice was it Mel blank I hate
rabbits toughest
it's embrace the Pecos it's incredibly
violent I just watched it yesterday with
my little ones and uh the puts a fish on
the hook Sylvester uh sorry puts a worm
on the hook for the fish and and then
the worm tries to crawl hook and crawl
back down the fishing line and he has a
44 magnum yeah
so why don't you shoot the fish
absolutely it's harder all right but
here's something else for uh before we
get to anything else uh this guy uh is
this is this is everything is brave and
beautiful and um I don't think Alex has
uh has seen this yet to Mr Jones but uh
I'm sorry let's watch
wow
is that real
ah something
damn
where'd you find him in a puppy mill
I'm gonna overbreed the brush remember
Shane it's terrible Alex remember that
was a thing yes shame
we bring it back like I'm a little
overweight and I'm ashamed of myself
this guy literally is like proud of the
disgustingness and then we're not even
supposed to say that's disgusting and
unhealthy no exactly definitely well but
I think toolman made a great point this
person was probably way more unhealthy
it's right lost a ton of weight and is
still tons of fun well that's no that's
the Victory lap exactly I think in that
look maybe the person's lost 300 pounds
well that wouldn't and then if that's
belly dancing and that's loose skin from
previous fat guy bud that's an unfair
advantage
well it is a stunning and brave young
lady look I actually met a woman this is
true I met a woman the other day who
told me that she and she's she said I
can I compete in drag queen shows and
she said but not with kids you're like
that I compete in drag queen shows I
said uh
I had some questions right because as
far as I knew this was a woman she goes
yeah you know and a lot of people say
that I shouldn't because I'm a woman you
know they say it's a an unfair Advantage
I'm like well yes yes if the point is to
win that she goes wow that's the next
level I love it so it's not just men
saying they're women now it's women
saying they're women against men who say
they're well yes and she was like the
only area a woman can beat a man is in
looks instead of the physical and you
can't ask her wow she figured out how to
game the system it was just oh my God we
gotta get you gotta get her on I don't
know if she'd want to be on the show
she's a wonderful beautiful
African-American woman where I go to
this establishment but it's just it's a
it's a place okay she serves food but
she was telling me about this it's a
brothel and she was saying some people
say it's an unfair Advantage like yes
yes you're a woman but you know if they
beat you at your swim meets then go beat
them the drag queen shows what can they
do they can't ask they can't dead name
her she just says my preferred pronouns
are they and them and there and they're
like well well crap I guess I guess we
lose this one
maybe maybe she just does a really good
job if they keep making Men Women of the
Year why can't we make a woman woman of
the year that's a good idea that's 100
stretch that's almost like the Inception
of uh what used to be considered normal
well exactly so we go all the way around
the Ark of insanity back to sanity yes
because now since Every Woman of the
Year every year for like five years is a
man someday it'll come back to a woman
yeah
[Music]
you can bring us back right after by the
way you don't need to sell sensor we
have the YouTube dump button so it's
fine it'll go on Rumble but it won't go
on YouTube if you are watching on
YouTube and you see this this button
there you go
that means head on over to rumble so we
took the elevator music yeah it's nice
it's soothing so so it's yeah how about
if I identify as Rachel Levine yeah like
if he's taking a woman's identity I can
now take his identity what if I say I'm
an admiral the deputy head of Human
Services myself oh well yeah I thought
you meant like steal a social security
number no I can do that too yeah if it
identifies that person sure yeah just
rack up a bill for like you know isn't
that fair yeah I mean I don't think it's
fair what have I identified I don't
think it's fair to put you in the truck
and then I identified laws against that
I don't think it's fair I think it's
morally imperative that you do that yes
yes I'll be disappointed in you if you
don't do it wear someone's skin like a
suit I'll tell you what's not confusing
this is a live show Monday through
Thursday 10 a.m Eastern we're trying to
get you off of passive consumption on
social media so just tune in bookmark it
the best place to go is Rumble you can
download the rumble app by the way so
notifications actually work
on the rumble app
and uh that's that's pretty intense that
looks good yeah mug Club is free
I feel like I have to download it now my
club is free uh all month so you go to
loudoun.com mug Club the Friday show
will only be on maybe not on Rumble
because it'll be streaming there on that
network uh but you get uh mug Club you
get Nick to follow show so uh by the way
this is revolutionary because nobody's
been able to Buck the system and win
like you are other than maybe Joe Rogan
going to Spotify but they still
massively censored so what you're doing
is revolutionary for everybody else
congratulations to the entire Lively
Crowder operation thank you and all the
viewers are making it happening look a
lot of people are watching don't want
this to be successful he's like my
height man he is I just wish the servers
were robust enough okay
it's not bragging him it's fact I mean
seriously we need Independent Media
that's already been you know number one
or number two to continue to be number
one and the fact that you're not bound
to censorship and winning is a
win-win-win for everybody
I understood maybe 40 of what you just
said but I very much appreciate the
spirit your Zeal well just imagine
they're again they're they've tried to
shut you down they try to control you
almost everybody else has gone along
with it and so if you can win and be
number one on a new independent platform
that is as awesome as it gets it'd be
like if the major car manufacturers say
you know a famous race 50 years ago a
lot of cases of this wouldn't let a new
car manufacturer put a car on the track
so they go through a multi-year battle
they finally get their new car on the
track and it wins the first big race and
it wins the next race that is a story of
innovation and a story of trailblazing
and Maverick activity for all of us do
you really think the frogs are gay
well that's an Alex Jones you know is an
authority moment
and no listen that was me like 12 13
years ago I saw a report right and a big
scientific study out of California where
the atrazine was turning the majority of
these frogs uh but basically gay because
they don't have sex with females they
tried to have sex with males and then so
their their numbers were plummeting then
I saw other studies out of South Africa
you name it and so it was just described
as it made them attracted to males and
so they were they were dying so I said
look I'm not against gay people I just
don't want to put chemicals in the Water
by the way you know no one would have
assumed that you were against gay people
you were saying was making frogs gay
they were like oh all right if I'm like
look I do not despise gay people I don't
find them gross they don't give me the
heebie-jeebies but
people like oh he doesn't like but I
don't want to put chemicals in the water
that turn the freaking frogs gay yes
because it does a lot of other bad
things to all of us and it's just
screwing everybody up and there's a lot
of chemicals in the food water and as we
expose that they were they remove them
like you know 20 years ago I was talking
about bisphenol Aid products here I
thought it was a cook that was some
major studies then about 10 years later
you try to go to Target or anywhere and
it says no bisphenol a in this product
so you know there's a lot of chemicals
that are gender mending and a lot of the
sperm count dropping the issues we have
is with a frog it totally you know fries
them yeah with a human it confuses them
and so that is where a lot of this uh
sexual uh no that's exact I mean it
happens a lot now women say don't worry
BPA happens to lots of guys
testosterone is down yeah testosterone
is down significantly but you know where
testosterone was up this is our first
story uh is uh the Donald Trump which
we'll be covering live by the way Donald
Trump indictment uh this obviously right
now the indictment watch is still in
full effect so there's not been any
indictment or arrest uh but the media of
course has been talking about this
absolutely you know Gerald not going
absolutely nuts of this this is their
Christmas yes it absolutely is ignore
the banks ignore what's going because uh
this is what we need to talk about
Manhattan district attorney Alvin Bragg
is considering whether to charge Trump
with falsified documents in connection
with the hush money payment to porn star
Stormy Daniels before the 2016 election
Republicans accused of playing politics
no matter whether there's an indictment
or not all the noise around he's all the
scrutiny all he can't even look his
hands are in group position is why we
don't have better people to pick from in
our politics now we're making a judgment
oh so you're saying it's too high a bar
to not pay off a porn star I'm not
judging it but I'm saying this obsession
with personal lives with Prosecuting our
political opponents I'm not saying it's
not a good case but I'm saying it sends
a message the circumstances that's
actually Fair what he was saying it was
yeah surprisingly or ex-president has
never in history been indicted for a
crime and that's exactly what hangs in
the balance never trust a man who has to
talk like I can understand men talk with
their hands like Italians but for Donald
Trump like this but Cuomo goes you know
we don't need to
he's like the guy that was trying to
cover the accent he's trying to cover
his hand move he's like yeah we don't
need to roll guys
look it runs the family what would he
say he said I'm Italian yeah that's an
excuse for being a rapist allegedly so
don't be mean to Fredo no hey that's an
insult to your people it's not not at
all it's not at all that's not an insult
it's an Intel to you it's an insult to
you you fake steroid taking rude but he
went in a little bit too hard on the
dang it intern no
he came to the defense too harshly for
the the paying off process I'm not
condemning paying off prostitutes
like he's because you've done it yeah
exactly look who Among Us has not paid
off a middling character actress
pornography star uh and of course groped
interns right let he who has not cast
the first stone just gets pelted with
rocks
so an indictment may be coming uh
obviously today as you know a Manhattan
grand jury hears the evidence okay
um and while we're talking about this
you know the security concerns obviously
during impossible uh arraignment uh
Trump is alleged to have told various
allies from the guardian over the
weekend that he didn't care someone shot
him he would become a martyr
oh I don't I don't there's so much crap
should be shown in handcuffs as well
yeah he did so this is definitely
boosting him over to Santa's it's
boosting him just across the board and I
think they're still going to go ahead
with the indictment but I love how the
media spun it like Trump's making it up
he's going to be indicted but it's great
we want him indicted yes exactly yeah
like no there's no indictment coming but
now that you mention it
[Laughter]
I told the Secret Service last week get
ready for next week we're gonna invite
him they're putting up the barricades
now they're having a little bit of cold
feet maybe they back off because again
it's never been done before I mean if
you're going to charge a president you
better find him with a dead kid in their
trunk or something not not yes seven
years ago statute of limitations is over
you have this idiot Soros uh you know
creature up there doing all this it's
it's not good I don't think he's an
idiot though sort of so I think it's far
more
oh his little minions no I totally agree
with you but I mean um just imagine just
imagine what happens if they actually do
this I think it'll probably still happen
what do you think uh well we'll be
covering it as it breaks I think there's
I would say 60 40 that it gets indicted
yeah and I think though they're probably
knowing what we know now they're
probably going to try and keep it quiet
so you guys comment below and by the way
uh smash so comment smash the rumble
button if you're on Rumble because
actually the algorithms on Rumble work
and head on over to rumble if you're on
YouTube please we'll be talking about
this where there's a mass Exodus taking
place you are the tip of the spear I
want to see that YouTube number go down
to zero like Ed Rooney his attendance
number
I don't remember YouTube having nine
viewers
uh and it's a free free month mug Club
lottoscar.com that's what keeps all this
going so that's what I think I think
they want to keep it quiet I think they
want to do it to damage him legally and
you know sort of hamper him with more
baggage going into the election but I
think that they don't want it to be a
public spectacle what were they thinking
of course it was going to be a spectacle
now that shows you this current Elite we
have if people are going to be corrupt
at least be smart about it they're just
so dumb yeah yeah about everything they
do but Donald Trump is also he
understands how to use the media for
this right if you're in a situation like
this where you have representation your
legal counsel is working with these
people basically you just decide on a
time and place to surrender that's not a
media event right maybe but here's what
he's going to do I would bet every
single dollar that I have that he goes
come and get me yeah he's like come the
rest over here you big horse's ass yeah
I'm calling the other cops you better
come out stab me that's exactly what I
think he's gonna do by the way the free
month there is no promo code for the
free month oh yes for rumble there's no
promo code it's just I'm asking about it
it's free it's free it's all all free
like Oprah with a van under your chair
so look let's get into this Donald Trump
and Ron DeSantis and I want to know what
you guys think genuinely you are a very
large focus group we have a huge sample
size yeah uh a lot of you were
protestantists a lot of you were
pro-trump I want to see if that's
flipped a little bit and how do you feel
about these two warring as they are so
barring president Trump being put in
actual prison uh it obviously seems
right now and there can always be a
surprise an October surprise or well
before that in the primaries nomination
is probably going to be him and Ron
DeSantis so um let's look at uh some of
I guess the sort of pros and cons with
both of them
um this coming now is it uh Pierce
Morgan yeah Pierce Morgan Pierce Morgan
interviewed Governor DeSantis and uh
some headlines were made this was
yesterday when they discussed the
Rivalry with Trump is this is this a
clip of DeSantis on Morgan I believe so
yes that's right okay because we have
the other clip later of him sort of you
know a little bit of a jab but this
whole interview hasn't been released
because Pierce Morgan really needs to
tease in order to generate some traffic
so let's watch what we have is your
favorite nickname that Trump's giving
you so far is it Ron Ronda sanctimonious
or meatball rock well I can't even he
went off meatball wrong I can't uh I
don't know how to spell the
sanctimonious I don't really know what
it means but I you know I kind of like
it's long it's got a lot of valve I mean
so we'd go with that that's fine you
know you can call me you can call me
whatever you want I mean just as long as
you you know also call me a winner
okay I don't like it no no what do you
think he should have come out firing or
what I thought he should just don't call
me late for supper you know something
like that now as long as you call me a
winner it's like first off your voice
needs to go down Alex take notes from
Alex Jones hello you call me a winner
you gay frog
but I did confront one of your lawyers
yesterday yeah I know well we'll we'll
get into that uh probably behind the
probably on well not pay well but the
free wall this month with mud clubs yeah
I keep screwing up the terminology uh so
in the interview which is going to be
airing Thursday uh Governor DeSantis
said that he thought he could win the
presidency he said uh if I were to run
I'm running against Biden uh like we him
and Trump are competing for the
Republican potentially I get that but
ultimately you know the guy I'm going to
focus on is Biden because I think he's
failed the country and then when he was
asked if he thought he could beat Biden
DeSantis just said I think so but he
said it he said it matter of fact yeah
you know what I mean so and you said I
think so it technically declared his
candidacy yet this is the stuff that
bothers me is like I'm not well why are
you in Iowa I know why are you in Iowa I
just came to see I just came to the
sightsee look there's some corn and
there's something there's some more corn
there's a buttercup well I got the power
that's pretty simple here well hold on a
second we're gonna get to that we have
to set it up first and then and then
we're gonna have Alex knows things
because we gave you a whole Stinger oh
yeah remember yeah I'm jumping the gun
again no no we have the Stinger free
because I want Alex walk into walls and
stuff I want Alex to be Alex we're like
look Alex we're gonna give you a wide
open in a stinger uh so according by the
way to to Morgan uh DeSantis uh tapped a
tapped attacked character and leadership
style and you already see this kind of
happening right on Monday DeSantis he
took his first count a little bit of a
jab at Donald Trump uh but then I do
want to read for you before we get into
the pros and cons the hilarious Trump
response
which is why the the largest part of me
as a host of a show really wants it to
be Trump but here is desantis's first
sort of shot over the bow you're talking
about this situation with and like I
don't know what goes into paying hush
money to a porn star to to secure
silence over some type of alleged Affair
I just I can't speak to that you can
guess oh damn
I can speak to
is that if you have a prosecutor
who is ignoring crimes happening every
single day in his jurisdiction and he
chooses to go back many many years ago
to try to use something about porn star
hush money payments you know that's an
example of pursuing a political agenda
so actually that's a obviously what he
was doing there was trying to highlight
something the character indictment but
his other response was relevant yeah of
course Donald Trump responded as he
would and this is what he posted on
truth so yeah this is weak but what he
said he said is all right I'm gonna try
and my voicemail I got that red tide
yeah
he said uh Rod dissect abodeish will
probably find out about false
accusations and fake stories sometime in
the future
sometime in the future folks I'm not
gonna say that I'm not gonna say when I
would never say what other people say
the future
maybe they have a DeLorean I don't know
could be lightning maybe it's a Freaky
Friday situ people swap bodies in the
future and they say what oh it's 20 26 I
don't know
sometime in the future as he gets older
why is there better known
but he's unfairly and illegally attacked
by a woman even classmates that are
quote underage or possibly a man folks
I'm sure he will want to fight these
Misfits just like I do now here's the
thing
um I will tell you this and by the way
all references are available at ladder
with crowder.com we always make them
available and we have researchers
working on this we search far and wide
as far as alleged future rumors
regarding Ron DeSantis with underage
classmates or possibly a man exclamation
point
we couldn't find any basis for these
rumors other than this picture with
which the left tried to make hay about
you know Rhonda Santos which they said
with you know underage girls but he
looks really young there yeah like they
don't it doesn't look like he's a 40
year old with sick or you know a 70 year
old with six-year-olds like it looks
like maybe he's 25 with like 20 year
olds which I don't know maybe is a
little weird maybe it's a little Matthew
McConaughey Dazed and Confused you know
I get older they stay the same age but
it doesn't mean that he's a pervert so
we couldn't find if there's something
please let us know I could find zero
bases for Donald Trump's uh truth social
post which is why it's hilarious yeah
but go back to that video on Ron
DeSantis don't don't actually put it up
but he actually did something that Trump
always does that we love about him where
he's like somebody told me or if people
say and it's like nobody says this he
goes I wouldn't know what it's like to
have to pay hush money I have no idea I
can't speak to that you know they just
throw in that little jab out there it's
like oh okay I'm surprised it's Donald
Trump didn't say that's because no porn
star would touch your pecker with a
10-foot Pole if it ever comes out by the
way that that happened and it's 100 and
be like she's the best porn star ever
he'll lean into it absolutely
um so what do you think the pros and the
cons are of uh the candidates let me
list you mine Gerald and then we've got
Alex uh Alex is it Alex knows we have
his whole step the truth recording the
truth but well because I want Alex to be
able to hit everything he wants to say I
think there are some pros here with
Donald Trump okay uh he will take the
fight to anyone anywhere I think that's
something that we know about Donald
Trump he was also probably the most
effective president during my lifetime
doesn't mean everything but as far as
when you compare him to George W Bush
when you compare him to George Bush
Senior where we're talking about
Republicans in my lifetime he certainly
got some stuff done not everything the
cons he'll often fight people and wage
Wars that he doesn't need to he doesn't
pick his spots and uh he often maybe
seems like he'll place his personal
grudges yeah over issues sometimes at
the cost of an issue that would be
winning for him DeSantis what do I like
he's followed through on his promises as
Governor mostly speaking you know he
talked about woke education you talk
about Disney he's the only conservative
outside of Donald Trump that I know of
who I think has been taking the fight to
the media you know actively calling them
out outside of Donald Trump they both do
that the cons
with DeSantis and I know this is a
common knock but I will tell you it does
worry me when he is he's not
independently wealthy yeah and so he is
going to be relying on I'm not saying
they're pulling the string certainly not
yet but he will be relying on other
donors which always comes with some
strings attached and he doesn't have any
experience doing this job exactly but
neither did Trump when he became
president president Trump didn't have it
so those are what I would say the pros
and cons of each Gerald so I would say
let me give you the pro of DeSantis
there's actually two things one I think
he's a little bit more polished than
Donald Trump is and so if he can develop
that part of his game like he did there
where he said I didn't I don't know what
it's like if he can do a little bit more
of that yeah polish I think that's
fantastic and two he does very well with
Independence better than Donald Trump
does right in a general election they're
forecasting he would do much better but
if you look at what he did in the State
of Florida when we covered the midterm
elections he killed it with Independence
right so if he can take that nationally
that's a very very good gameplay he
doesn't do as well with people of a
color well yeah so voters that's the pro
the pro for Donald Trump he does very
well nationally with people of color and
that's going to be a huge voting block
we talked about that yesterday the
blacks he'll he'll take it to the media
in all new ways but the problem with
Donald Trump is that he probably brings
too much baggage into a general yeah
right there's too many people that would
that would suit up to fight against him
Ron DeSantis doesn't inspire people to
fight against him quite the same way
right but he also doesn't inspire people
to fight for him true that's true quite
the same way and of course I'm sure
someone has very very lofty opinion
lengthy opinions and this is time for
Alex Jones
well whatever hit this truth according
I don't know why they added that at the
end I like it
I meant to be a joke it's like Socrates
said I know that I know nothing well you
know what it is if you use what the left
tries to use against you if you use it
as it inoculates you well
yeah of course I walked into your wall
yesterday that's proving you're not
deity I mean we're all kind of
yeah I literally just like it is it is
obviously a joke but I do have a room
temperature IQ I wear a leather helmet
but it's a joke well I told you guys
today maybe I should host a show with a
helmet on yeah I know we just didn't
have one that would fit that melon
there's Billy we've got it we have to
wear wigs today too
you must have did you dream that oh no
that was the contest the beauty contest
oh yeah well no you said that and then
we promptly said no so Donald Trump and
Ron DeSantis where do you line up what
do you think the pros and cons are of
each because you were obviously very big
on Trump early on and then you've had
some qualms of them but we do with that
you do with everybody you're fair I
think what you and Gerald said really
mixed together is the whole field of the
issue uh DeSantis is very very polished
they won't be able to manipulate him as
much but I like how Trump takes it to
the Deep State I love how much The
Establishment hates him but what Gerald
said
Trump polarizes things and gets the left
to commit crimes and do things they've
never done before
[Music]
even admit election
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
people who didn't know about the hunter
Biden laptop story that would have
changed the election they admitted
exactly so so without waiting into the
machines and all that I think that's a
red herring but what I was getting it is
you don't think Mike Lindell spot on not
not about the south
foreign
[Music]
they hate him they're scared of them
they've tried to destroy him he's come
back so much you want to see him get in
there but then it kind of feels like
we're playing with chaos yeah and at the
same time uh I'd like to see what the
Santos do but but I I lean more towards
Trump because of this
the sandwich being endorsed by Jeb Bush
to Santa's saying his greatest Idol is
George Herbert Walker Bush father of the
modern New World Order uh DeSantis being
the darling I want to cause you one
second here just because I think that
second part was very important when he
was endorsed by Jeb Bush I was like well
whatever Jeb Bush can endorse whoever he
wants
well that quote you're talking about
with George H.W bush that's far more
concerning because that's Rhonda Center
saying these are examples absolutely you
can say well he's not really skull and
moans he was in another secret society
yell fine but then when you pull back
and he's like no I admire most George
Herbert Walker Bush gross I mean that's
like Rockefeller Republican that's a
Democrat who became president and then
we basically got Clinton and then Obama
and you know and and W before that all
of it out of that CIA whole Dynasty and
so
I see that most troubling also he's not
been as anti-war As Trump has been and
so I think Trump right now is in the
lead with me because he's anti-war and
because the establishment doesn't like
him but at the same time I don't like
the worship of trump I don't like his
kids I mean I like Don Jr but I don't
like the Kushner and the daughter and
and just you know and then all the cute
people thinking Trump's invincible and
worshiping him yeah so so there's a sort
of like the nfts but none of us have a
problem with Baron
I don't want royalty right I remember
just three years ago they were bragging
the kids were bragging not done but the
other one's about how we're going to be
a dynasty and we're we're new royalty
and I'm like throwing up yeah okay I
don't want to get rid of the globalist
royalty and replace it with some new you
know royalty okay I I want my Republic
back and if Trump wants to secure the
border secure the dollar bring jobs back
you know put fentanyl dealers you know
on death row I mean if Trump wants to do
that that's great and stop the sensors
that's nothing Trump sat there and I
briefed him other people briefed him
about how they were censoring how it was
big Tech how was Intelligence agencies
the money Obama put in in January 2021 I
mean January 2017 before he left yeah
into the defense authorization act in
the rebuild and and it's all in there
it's all in that act uh the countering
foreign act and that's how they declared
the American people as terrorists and
his enemies and had this illegal
government operations surveillance spy
and censor okay for me it's much bigger
than the first amendment it's that whole
program and Trump sat there and let that
happen he didn't do enough that's why
I'm angry at him yeah well so he never
thought I will get sensing I don't
really need my fans who do you think so
I and I agree with you right it comes
down to okay we have really two
questions here who is the best person
for the job in the current state of
affairs but really it's it does come
down to who does better in the general
yeah right that's a big concern because
if Trump for some reason I don't agree I
I I understand what you're saying as far
as winning the general but I also I
understand where Alex is it's far more
concerning to me that we get somebody
who wins a general who's a puppet you
know I think we're at the point if
you're going to lose lose big but I just
don't think Ron DeSantis is that puppet
he's not perfect no no I'm not saying
that either Florida he's done a good job
so if he continues doing that I would
rather have him with a chance to win if
that's a big if if for some reason Trump
is predicted like well it comes back to
Hillary Clinton like he was projected
not even to come close to me no I'm
gonna throw so I get that but if we look
at it and go gosh it's going to be
really hard I would hate for Biden or
somebody like whoever else they throw up
there to have just a well you know by
the way Biden has degenerated so much I
know that now he can't even talk yeah I
know but there's a new video he can
still sniff though his family all right
well we have so much else together but
you know what you guys comment below
DeSantis Donald Trump and by the way if
you're on YouTube head on over to rumble
do hit the like all that stuff on
YouTube just to help us because that
helped the algorithm but head on over to
rumble it's free all month we have a
bunch that we are going to be discussing
today that we could absolutely never
discuss on YouTube but you get to watch
for free this has been the truth
according to Alex
now I do have to hit this we have some
breaking news here I don't know if you
know this there's been a seaweed blob
twice the width of the United States oh
wow currently floating toward the
Florida coast it's been covered all over
the news uh just so you know nothing up
our sleeves that CNN has been all over
this
Professor shelman who is one of the
leading experts on what many have
referred to as a massive blob of seaweed
heading to Florida's Coast fair to call
it a blob
you say no that's reporting that right
there if you could call it a blob nope
nope good enough for me
this time of year always do this yeah I
know but it still is concerning uh the
world is going to end Alex let's not
let's not you know she's right yeah the
world is ending it's a 5 000 mile wide
blob it's made of a specific type of
seaweed called uh sargassum or sargassum
I don't care you can comment below and
correct me uh scientists obviously uh
have been saying that this could be the
largest Bloom ever so we actually now we
have the exclusive thank you for signing
up and supporting mukla that allows us
to get boots on the ground we now go to
on the ground reporter Thomas Finnegan
thank you
all right do we have him there Mr
Finnegan Hey Stephen thanks for having
me uh well the seaweed is in the water
and it is getting closer to the beach
with every passing minute okay well that
makes sense do you have any more
information Insight that would uh
legitimize me sending you out there with
our budget
to the beach not yet but give me some
time because this is a developing
problem and I'm keeping a close eye on
it yeah well it seems to that okay I
guess then we'll we'll check back in
with you
uh I think I see a crab do they bite I
don't think that's I don't think they do
um but I have no idea I'm not a marine
biologist good luck with that Thomas
Finnegan uh have a good reporting season
thank you it's getting closer
[Music]
thank you
all right head on over to rumble mug
Club is free and of course do not go to
Mad maxworld.tv where Alex Jones will
not be streaming at noon 11 Eastern this
is something that I really did want to
talk about we'll talk about the massive
YouTube Exodus that's taking place and
we're incredibly grateful uh for you
because this is an inflection moment in
history but before that
you know culture at large we've talked
about this and Alex you're a little bit
older than I am um and I mean we're all
kind of in different age demographics I
will say this the United States has
never been more racist or racially
divided uh than today and I don't mean
because white people are being more
racist than ever I mean the perception
of racism has never been more intense in
my lifetime uh than today so that's what
I want I want to use as a jumping off
point this went viral yesterday where
there was a couple with their child
being confronted by a very aggressive
racist uh which brings us to well first
New York state of crime
[Music]
[Applause]
okay if you have kids they should leave
the room because it's a pretty rough
video to watch but everyone else is
talking about it and then I'd like to
use it as a jumping off point to discuss
kind of some changes that you may not be
aware of culturally that have taken
place that have racially divided you and
hey you know what Alex Jones was right
it's by Design so uh get your kids out
of the room just because it's a little
bit disturbing five four three two real
quick
foreign
[Music]
how the media will cover it that I tell
you that that man is completely
interticulate has no Mastery of the
English language and made up words
they'll say well that's racist
no I'm talking about that right
there and he did he called somebody a
white monkey again Ron Perlman it would
fit that guy doesn't really look like a
white monkey if the shoe were on the
other foot not saying you should ever go
out and call racial minorities or people
of color voters of color monkeys of
course you shouldn't neither should he
he made up words trying to sound
articulate this is one thing that you
guys need to know okay uh having spent a
lot of time and we talked about this
with the Hodge twins if you go back and
watch an old episode uh someone one time
let me tell you the story someone one
time tried to kidnap uh tried to steal
my I guess dog Jack back in the day
hopper before Joe Lewis it was in
Oklahoma stopping at the Choctaw Casino
to fill up on gas had driven across the
country get out and he goes hey man
that's my dog I said uh no this is
actually this is his name's popper he
was he's from Detroit he's a rescue he
goes man that's my dog you better give
me my dog back I know what it is it's a
doggo Argentino that's my dog and I put
him in my car and I walked out and I
said uh no he's not I don't know what
your problem he said ah I don't even my
dog though and he walked away and the
Hodge twins told me they said yeah yeah
I said it's something that we were
taught to do young I said we couldn't
white boy pumpkin
we take the Sega Genesis and take
it all they talked about how often a lot
of young black men are taught that white
men are passive and weak and I saw this
at the mall this week I saw a group of
uh black women who were who were a
boisterous I should say and largely
clothesless and they bumped a few people
right they just bumped into a few people
and I watched another black gentleman
with his wife he was kind of bumped and
he just said like hey watch where you're
going said this to the black lady yeah
that same black lady was still on her
phone
bumped a white woman who was wearing a
little you know one of those little like
kind of Patchouli looking you know looks
like she would wear Patchouli but a
beanie and she went oh
and spoke to her husband like I guess I
guess because I need to check my
privilege guess what we can't have a
society that has one group of people
believing that other people are weak and
easily intimidated therefore you should
do it to right the wrongs of the past
and let me give you some more examples
here the media is rolling I don't know
if you remember when Elon Musk by the
way actually African-American made news
with this tweet where he said that the
media is racist for a very long time Us
Media was racist against non-white
people now they're racist against whites
and Asians same thing has happened with
Elite colleges and high schools in
America maybe they can try not being
racist let's compare
how the very same media covered the
Tweet everything he just said there by
the way is factually verifiable
Asians at Elite colleges high schools in
America that is a fact there are
lawsuits that are being won the media
covered African-American Elon musk's
tweet
with this Elon Musk the CEO of SpaceX
Tesla on Twitter accused the media and
Elite colleges and high schools of being
quote racist against white and Asian
people espousing his views without
providing evidence on Sunday where could
he have possibly pulled that stat
and by the way I don't know if you saw
this remember the Rasmussen poll they
asked people black people it's okay to
be white only 53 percent of blacks
agreed 47 of black Americans sorry
people of color weren't sure that is
incredibly disconcerting that means that
there's a 50 50 shot when you're walking
down the streets right now if you see a
black American
there's a 50 50 shot that they don't
know if they think you have the right to
exist and that's what Scott Adams got
into yeah yeah I'd like to comment on
that yes people need to know the roots
of this so back when it was okay to be
racist against black people 100 years
ago there was like a million KKK members
and they had giant marches in DC and by
the 70s there was you know maybe twenty
thousand of them and and everybody
dislikes them the corporate media and
the universities and everything on
record to divide the country and uh you
know to to
well I basically bring the country down
know that the country's going to be a
majority non-white and so whether
they're Latin American or whether
they're people that are already here
that are black that are Americans the
universities the culture is teaching
them you've been screwed over you've
been wrong by this group of people yeah
and so literally it's the most racist
thing on earth the opposite of Martin
Luther King said that was totally true
judge people by what they do what they
create what they stand for and that's
what we should be doing but instead no
one is calling out the white leftists
that are teaching this the Hollywood the
media that promotes it and then you're
going to have a large minority
of black people uh you know a minority
of that Minority who are going to buy
into this because they see it in the
media they believe it's normal now and I
see this Rasmussen poll I don't believe
that actual number that's how they pitch
it that's how they skew it but but but
what it is is people white people will
tell you they've done polls is it okay
to be white and they say no no you can't
wear that shirt like I've seen similar
numbers where the majority are closer to
white people won't say that or if you
try to sell that shirt on a lot of you
know shopping cart platforms they'll
take your thing away shirt a white shirt
no it's okay to be white oh okay oh yeah
yeah that's what I'm getting it
with the political correctness some of
them are racist some of them have you
know drunk the Kool-Aid and and been
brainwashed but most of them are just
just like the white people bowing down
the black lives matter they believe it's
the right thing to say well maybe it
isn't good if you want to bully pulpit
and people are intimidated and let me
give you some stats here just so you
know how this it has flipped like Alex
is talking about yeah and it's they've
been successful with a lot of this so in
2012 most people viewed race relations
in America as positive black Americans
viewing them as 66 white American 72 by
2015. that's three years the percentage
had declined sharply so we went from 66
with black Americans down to 51 percent
went even lower with white Americans it
went from 72 to 45 percent 72 percent
viewed race relations favorably down to
45 yes like you said in fact maybe show
the graphics again I'm wrong no no
you're right those are important show me
again but those are important so people
can see the contrast right black
Americans went from 66 favorable to 51
which means not a shepherd of a decline
which means that black Americans aren't
buying the from the media as
much as white Americans are 72 down to
45. that's the problem so white
Americans become passive and they become
intimidated you know what the worst
thing is if you actually want to
interact on a day-to-day basis with
black Americans and be able to have a
friendly relate is to not be intimidated
passive you know what black men don't
respect that's the truth culture
I don't think anybody likes that I mean
look that's what's happening the left
yeah but literally once everybody they
don't even like eating it look it's very
simple George Soros I agree George Soros
and the globalists have put billions of
dollars into black lives matter to take
over any type of black movements to
Simply put a black face on the globalist
agenda and then tell everybody else bow
down to our agenda or you're racist and
it's not even a black agenda but there
are black people that are buying into
the fact that whites are inherently bad
and get in their face and when people do
that people need to get back in their
face and let them know that's not okay
well here's something too that when I
was raised you know I was raised in
Canada which is a silly place uh but it
was basically a post-racial uh America
Canada Canada is like America light
right but then I noticed later on you
would have kids trying to identify with
the American ghetto like for example
Drake Drake is a butter soft from
a nice wealthy area of Toronto he played
the Jewish kid undergrassi who couldn't
outrun the school shooter and he had to
wheel around like Stephen Hawking
without the mouthpiece and now he's
talking like he's from Memphis so
there's a lot of uh sort of there's this
desire to be a part of a culture that by
the way isn't necessarily indicative of
actual black American culture oh you're
a white guy talking about this well you
know what don't take my word forward
again all references available at
lottery.com hey when we were young and
even before that you had uh The
Jeffersons that went on for a very long
time right but the Cosby Show
before he raped you know like 95 people
allegedly but we just didn't know the
process had started but we didn't know
yeah yeah Peak viewership and I had to
double check this was it 62 million per
episode it was the number one show in
America for Five Seasons The Fresh
Prince of Bel-Air reached a peak
viewership of 20 million per episode it
turned Will Smith into a movie star
right Empire though now we fractured
everything now it's white people watch
this and we create content for black
people it used to be hey everyone can
watch it now colleges are bringing
segregation but yes but let's put Empire
17 million then it dropped to 2.9
Million viewers for the season
think about we were a country that was
so racist that our number one show was
The Cosby Show the number one show that
we would watch would be the Fresh Prince
of Bel-Air and family matters you
skipped over step by step no one's a
Patrick Duffy but you saved it for Urkel
and what did this the global of social
Engineers it's all documented literally
put Obama and he did get elected very
popular people thought it was the
promise of us all coming together
instead he creates major racial
divisions Hollywood producers all the
movies they create and they opened all
these wounds up to culturally control us
now and that's their agenda the good
news as you said is minorities more and
more are actually rejecting it and going
with people like Trump but it is mainly
white women and I'm not attacking white
people but it's just true it is white
women on average who are the leftists
who are driving this cult and so it's
not about kissing black people's ass the
left claims that's what they want no
it's about we own the black people we
own representing them do what we say or
you're racist we have to reject this
it's ridiculous and to be clear that's
the media saying we own just to be clear
right someone's gonna take a quote of we
own black people and they're going to
try and use that no I'm saying the left
thinks they don't I mean remember what
I'm just trying to save you from
said yes if you don't vote for me you
ain't black yeah from some weird crazy
Pro KKK guy yeah I know I'd be like shut
the hell up like like if you don't vote
for me you're not an American I would
immediately if somebody told me if you
don't vote for me you're not you're not
white I'd be like we're even making it
racial yeah it doesn't mean people all
they do is obsessed with race because
it's a dying out of control Elite that's
falling apart the Democratic Party The
Party The KKK the party of Jim Crow the
party of racial division the party of
collapsing cities the party of Fraud and
evil absolutely always and they're
trying to tell you other parties
switched no they didn't go do a little
bit of actual research on Strom Thurmond
your only example but I do agree with
what he said about white women
ain't but hoes and tricks what are we
about to say there I was gonna say when
I was growing up in the 80s and 90s
right we've talked about this we were
watching this like we it never it was
never cleared I was very very low income
and so I have very mixed school I had a
lot of Hispanics a lot of Asians a lot
of blacks all of us we were fine yeah we
didn't have any of these problems they
want to you to believe it again it's
it's a lie that you can't disprove they
go you were fine well no the stats show
that more black people thought they were
fine they say you're white it's easy for
you to say let's say this there were
some problems because I grew up in
Dallas of course but but so did I but
but let's be clear it's a lot worse now
in the numbers it's far far away I was
just watching the very first episode the
other day of Sesame Street and I
actually want to show you a comparison
of then where nobody even thought twice
of people of all different races where
it didn't come up hanging out with each
other and it was supposed to be a
friendly Street Big Bird's head's a
little bit weird this is 1969 and then
we'll compare it to now
Sally you 've never seen a street like
Sesame Street everything happens here
you love it they're playing play games
just say hi Bob hi say hello to Sally
she just moved into the neighborhood hi
Sally that's Bob nice to see you
greetings my friends
for your paper thank you yes come here
it's Uber come here say hello to Sally
hello she just moved to the neighborhood
welcome to Sally all right that's enough
Mr Hooper kind of he's kind of a dick
that is a child you don't have to be so
cold
hello welcome Sally come on Mr Hooper
put a little bit of effort into it let's
compare it to Sesame Street explaining
race and by the way that's so important
because people don't know it was passive
because it was real people just wanted
to put the racial tensions to bed we're
not perfect but the way to move on now
they want to totally screw these kids up
well here you go here's them uh
comparing uh well let's compare it to
them explaining race now but
that's a good question number well it's
because the more melanin you have the
darker your skin looks
the color of our skin is an important
part of Who We Are
yeah and then Nick Cannon guessed it and
said because if you don't have enough
melanin you got no soul
well that is true about about redheads I
love redheads by the way
oh you love all heads by the way I want
to say something you're like the Jesus
Christ of ladies red and yellow black
and white they're all sexy I don't think
we cover monkeys or Ames but humans are
humans are all of us uh somewhat look a
little bit Simeon and I don't look like
a monkey I kind of look like a gorilla
and I even kind of walk like one of you
notice so sometimes you do yeah but
that's because you swam a lot I thought
it was a lot stretch because I've got no
Achilles over here and I'm I'm a little
overweight yeah well you know what
you're kind of look like a penguin do
you know what your Achilles heel is
yes you love too much ah I do you love
too deeply that's been New York state of
crime
dreams
[Music]
[Applause]
all right and by the way smash the
rumble button hit like if you're on
YouTube comment please if you are
watching on YouTube head on over to
rumble we have a whole segment today
about about Philadelphia and reparations
I don't know how many dump buttons have
been hit today but it's quite a bit I'm
also going to get into some stuff that
is super secret that YouTube does not
want you to know so you definitely need
to go over on Rumble right now where
it's free no promo code free for the
next month hey and share the link right
now do it right now I feel like he
should be emptying deaf Comedy Jam like
y'all ready for your next deck is funny
as he's like that boy good yeah
that should be Ste apostrophe then that
would be a good name so um look here's
one thing and this is I don't want to we
always try and avoid sort of tooting our
own horn but this is something this is
you and I want you to take this as a
Victory lap Gerald CEO now has told me
that it's important to celebrate the
wins it is I'm kind of a Hermit I'm kind
of reclusive I've always sort of come up
under the stoic mindset of you know the
work should be its own reward but you
guys have made this possible so let me
explain to you as we went to rumble a
little bit
uh what we expected coming back right
and we obviously there were contractual
issues and that kept us from coming back
and we were working this entire time but
we all expected as we were transitioning
we're talking about YouTube and Rumble
we all expected to see a temporary dip
in viewership as we Diversified it uh
Diversified it I'm talking like the guy
on the subway as we Diversified it we my
mercified it and then I'm about to crack
firstified it what what are you saying
ah shut up white devil so we all
expected to see a temporary dip in
viewership as we Diversified and
migrated you toward rumble meaning we
all know that Rumble has a much smaller
user base than YouTube everyone knows
that that's not an insult to them
um and we were willing to sacrifice some
short-term gain in order to achieve the
long-term goal of divesting uncoupling
whatever you want to call it from
YouTube I don't think any of us here
I don't think anyone correct me from
expected to see significantly greater
viewership on Rumble than before we left
uh at all oh yeah some people were sick
of the big Tech they want to make the
move that's why your decision and
working with Rumble so good did you
expect that Gerald so I I did not I when
I saw it I literally had the guys they I
never do this right you were giving me a
hard time for being on my phone they
were letting me know how many viewers we
had and I I said is that is that a typo
yeah is that a typo for live viewership
it was it's better than some of the very
best live shows we've done on YouTube
right the streams the live streams you
guys have been right up there at the top
you know number one routinely and I'm
telling you I've been there with Joe
Rogan well there's 150 000 live things
in the other show is 30 million views
they're they're like a static over that
right yeah so so I mean getting that on
Rumble is crazy wasn't just the live
views no it's not just the live views
they've also by the way this is for
users out there they fixed the uh the
sort of algorithm that determines the
views because it used to be lower than
YouTube Yeah because it didn't calculate
the churn rate which again we're going
to probably on a mug Club let's see how
people are watching and what the poll
says as far as how people are watching
but this this kind of proves three
things and please just stick with me for
a second because this has to do with you
let's go back to then with some of our
shows there's been a flip
okay when I say flip YouTube is the
place that would generate viewers and
people would say Hey you have to be on
YouTube to generate new viewers and I
understand that you want to reach the
unreach and then Rumble was the mirror
for a lot of people it was a safety
right my first choice is Oxford and the
sarbone but my safety is Harvard so
Jordan Peterson versus Olivia Wilde was
a show that we did this is back
September 7th 2022 on YouTube it did 1.4
million on Rumble it did 243 000. and by
the way none of these numbers include
the audio or the mug club numbers these
are just Rumble and YouTube okay then
let's uh look at another show back then
Alex Jones on Kanye West where we talked
about that thank you for the traffic by
the way uh
on YouTube it did close to a million 986
000 on Rumble it did 514 000. wow okay
so Rumble was always significantly lower
but we see the trends upward yes so now
here's the flip and this is what's
exciting for everybody out there because
I want to discuss this with you content
creators and people who are watching
okay and why there's a vision here that
we are genuinely amped up it's a
revolution for everybody it really is it
provides this for everyone
they always say go build your own thing
they'll never let anybody nobody's ever
done it you and rumbles are finally
doing too many people on the right don't
want to build their own thing so this
brings us back to we came back the Trump
arrest okay first episode Back YouTube
662 000 that's fine Rumble 2.1 million
yesterday's show on YouTube 370 000 on
Rumble 1.6 million so you're looking at
shows that uh will be
two and a half three first show three
million individual screens per show this
proves to us three things let me get
into this here and this is why this
affects you directly because I know a
lot of you have been looking for a
reason right a lot of you have been
looking for a reason for a a mass Exodus
YouTube's engagement is less valuable we
now have contrast where we know that
they haven't been honest so on Rumble by
the way the notifications work you can
actually find what you want if you're
going through a channel nothing's
perfect and by the way I would love for
you to comment below what changes you
would like to see on Rumble because they
are working incredibly fast they have
grown incredibly fast but I'd like to
see the changes that you most want
um pound for pound no if you are a
Creator out there you can do far better
on Rumble now than you could on YouTube
that wasn't true six months ago number
two I said did one but number two uh it
shows that people
You are not alone remember there are
more of you than them that's why they
got rid of the dislike button because it
started showing up that oh my God people
are going to realize that there's more
of them if they look at every single
Trump White House video like to dislike
versus former vice president pedophile
Joe Biden they got rid of it there are
more of you than them and this proves
that it shows that there are a lot of
people like you out there who are just
waiting for a reason for an excuse to
take part in The Exodus from YouTube and
this is something that I suspected while
we were all told that we were wrong the
business model on the right was look you
have to be on YouTube period you have to
be monetized on YouTube but let me
explain uh why I'll get here to the
third uh the third Point um why there is
this Exodus taking place here's
something that's important to note okay
truth social is going to have a hard
time
anything that's trying to take over
Facebook or Twitter is going to have or
let's say Instagram is going to have a
hard time why it's a social media site
there's a very big difference between a
media site and social media this is
what's exciting about Rumble and you're
the spirit you're the tip of the spirit
with Mud Club right that's proof of
product for a rumble premium product but
media is different from social media why
people say go over to truth social okay
but why are you on Facebook your uncle
your you're there because all of your
friends and family are there and you go
I'm on truth so I'm on one of these
other places but my family isn't there
but you are not on YouTube because
you're interacting with your family you
are on YouTube because it is where the
content resides that you want to watch
that's very different this is why people
go to content let's say Netflix HBO Max
YouTube is an example people are there
to watch content not to hang out and
socialize and people are ready to leave
YouTube but and this is a call to action
out there it depends on the content
creators it's just like when David
Letterman went from uh NBC to CBS people
didn't say well I'm I'm an NBC guy they
said well okay I want to go watch David
Letterman so YouTube is very there is a
way to fracture this and for an exodus
to take place if we all keep fighting
about it being absolutely perfect in the
platform and the app which you can
download look bear with us but the
critical mass of users can easily leave
YouTube which can't happen with Facebook
or Instagram and I think it's already
happening that's why I'm so excited
about this and and you said it something
that's been around 15 years or whatever
like Facebook it has billions of users
it's falling apart but still that's
where everybody's at that's not the
first Domino to fall it will be content
creation platforms like rumble or our
smaller uh band.video and once that
diversifies and when people go get their
content from there then out of those you
can then build the social networks and
the new systems around those right and I
think you say we can hit critical mass I
think day three on your show having
almost 2 million viewers on Rumble and
and 1.7 you know yesterday and all the
rest of it I think you've reached the
critical mass and then once there's
proof of this everybody's gonna go to
rumble and as long as they don't get
bought out or controlled or shut down
that will be the Chain Reaction well
here's the beauty too because Rumble
yeah it's a publicly traded company but
they're only as valuable as their
protection of free speech right until
the French government well go screw
yourselves if you want to get rid of
Rumble if you want to ban us so they've
kind of painted themselves in a corner
which they've willingly done and here's
something else too this is something
that is and I appreciate the point I
think you're right I don't think we've
hit critical map we have ourselves where
we don't have to rely on YouTube but
what I want is none of you to have to
rely on YouTube it's the first one
you've reached critical mass and your
gamble was right you believe in the
people so far this is spectacular you
guys you know I've got to be excited but
exactly the big critical mass you guys
could be like the smaller critical mass
that causes a larger critical mass kind
of like with uh some types of atomic
bombs or hydrogen bombs they fire a a
uranium bullet into a block of plutonium
so you guys have already reached
critical mass and now we're firing the
uranium into the plutonium I'm not a
nuclear physicist but I'll take your
word for it that's correct so here's one
thing that I do want to say though I
think he's Pro I'm sure he's right uh I
just can't verify it just so you know so
don't hold me to it so this is something
else too when conservatives out there
say that YouTube and Facebook
today what are we March 22nd starting
today going forward March 22nd 2023
everyone mark this down in your calendar
this is what we are excited about this
is what gets us out of bed in the
morning going forward from today
whenever conservatives say that YouTube
or Facebook are integral to the business
model meaning we have to make sure that
all conservatives look that's where
people are we have to go on YouTube we
have to make sure we're monetized we
have to make sure that no one gets
suspended on Facebook that's a choice
that's a choice now it's a choice that
everyone can make
but it's a clear one so remain on
YouTube or even worse remain monetized
on YouTube continue lining Google in
YouTube's Pockets while living a life of
self-censorship hoping that they kill
you last or
you have door number two take your
audience where they want to follow you
anyway which by the way is anywhere else
the whole staying on YouTube and by the
way I don't mean using YouTube or
uploading Clips that's great I think you
should but using it as the fulcrum of
your media model moving forward now is a
choice you are choosing to be in
business with YouTube at this point over
other alternatives
because now there are alternatives a lot
of Alternatives I sound like a stroke
like a former vice president pedophile
Joe Biden because they are now
officially viable so right now out there
if you are a Creator if you're a
producer if you're a company you can you
can migrate off of YouTube and you can
keep your viewership you don't have to
sacrifice it you can earn a living
and you can build your business on an
alternative like Rumble maybe there will
be other places right now rumbles the
game in town as far as enough viewers
and as far as the capabilities while
still you can do all this while still
using YouTube to reach new people but
not being in bed with them YouTube does
not have to be your main video delivery
platform anymore no company is perfect
but at this point you are choosing
Rumble over YouTube you are but if you
choose to be monetized on YouTube that's
you making a choice to choose YouTube
over Rumble you are choosing their rules
you are choosing their shackles over the
freedom of another platform now if you
want to speak freely
if you wanna the the whole I was just
doing my job excuse
that's done it can no longer be used
because it also wasn't required for
business it's dead it's done now there's
an alternative and you don't have to
compromise and that is something
exciting everyone out there you're a
content creator head on over and we hope
to see you there yeah absolutely and
that's what I love one other point I
wanted to make is no that's absolutely
right like it's a proof of concept but
here's what we did it takes work for two
years we've been using YouTube or Rumble
and saying hey if we're not on YouTube
we are on Rumble right paid out big time
for us because we would get strikes we
wouldn't be able to Air and in the past
we just were dead for a week right we
wouldn't be streaming anywhere so
two-way content creator right now create
a rumble page as well it's not going to
hurt you to have an alternative
especially when YouTube comes up and
you'll get more views on Rumble well
you've got to have it I mean plus
rumble's transition you'll get more
views that's the thing you will get it
used to be like uh okay at least I won't
be censored but I won't have as many
people watching now you won't be
censored and you'll have more people
watching isn't that exciting because
you're not throttled every single person
on the right should be excited about
that by the way you don't have to have a
business relationship with Rumble you
probably don't you don't have one with
YouTube just go and put it somewhere
where you'll get more views because I
know your audience gets because we've
been beaten over the head with it but
but it's so true I don't get up here and
say something's historic get excited so
we started running the wall and almost
cut my nose off for no reason to get 170
000 to get 1.7 million views on Rumble
the second day you move over I know
inside YouTube is turning a lot of heads
and again they tried to censor they try
to control we see Joe Rogan who's a
great guy go to Spotify and everybody
had an exit it's there but they censored
just as much as YouTube and so it's very
exciting maybe not just as much but but
some strings attached well it goes on I
mean I'm not saying with Joe but with a
lot of the other shows people are
getting yeah yeah with other shows taken
down so what I'm saying is it's good to
see that rumble's telling the truth it's
good to see that so quickly it's really
having success and I agree with you I
think you're going to see if the
audience stays excited right now we'll
be able to look back on this in six
months and say this was basically the
end of YouTube being the place for
conservative populist and national news
and by then they'll be begging just like
The Joe Rogan clips from Spotify they'll
be begging for rumble Clips over there
and so you'll just have highlights of
Stephen Crowder over there they'll have
more viewers than ever and it just shows
how they're arrogant they're
disconnected they think they're God they
think they can censor us and lie about
us it's not going to work and they think
the left can sit over there on YouTube
like in the case of myself and lie about
me and I can't respond so that's why I
appreciate you Stephen and your crew is
you stood up for me four or five years
ago when I was being targeted at no
other place outside of my own you know
uh Phantom so they put me in an Infowars
to be able to communicate I could talk
to my audience but I could never respond
to lies they were telling exactly so I'm
very thankful for you and and again I
see your success is my success and I see
it as all the viewers and listen to
success so what you're saying is not
even a a a offer or request I think
everybody including folks that have
never really created content should go
to rumble because Rumble in the fight
for free speech is doing more than
Trump's done more than con Congress is
doing more than Jim Jordan more than
these hearings Stephen Crowder and
Rumble and what they're doing is doing
more than all those guys combined this
is action this is exciting because we
don't have free speech in a platform to
fight the globalists we're going to lose
if we have a platform it will cause a
revolution an exodus and a whole new
Renaissance of free media not
distributed worldwide and America can
again be the leader in free speech not
the leader in censorship you are a
Marvel love it love it it's always fun
having Alex Jones by the way we did not
plan maybe there's some way you know
what maybe we'll put out a poll if
there's some way for uh you know mug
club members to get access also to uh
mad maxworld.tv if there's a way to you
know where they can get access to all of
it again and the beauty is all of these
contracts are independent people take
their subscribers they get to keep their
subscribers everyone who signed with us
will announce when Nick depalo shows
coming in announce the comedy specials
here next week tomorrow we also have
Brian Cowan the show we'll be talking
about theology there's a Friday show
please do smash the rumble button and
there's one month free of mug Club you
don't have to pay you just have to sign
up you don't have to have turn your
credit card info you'll probably do that
at the end of the month we get you a
little bit addicted to this and then you
know it's like it's like the crack
cocaine from what I understand but
before we go uh and it's a live show
Monday through Monday through Thursday I
want to say Tuesday that'd be two days
boy Monday through Thursday uh 10 a.m
Eastern and of course Alex Jones is mad
maxworld.tv go and watch him uh well
don't watch him don't and don't go to
that place that doesn't exist at noon uh
11 Eastern but because I'm not having uh
Robert Barnes fill in in the first hour
a great lawyer really smart guy on the
uh Trump indictment arrest watch and
then I'll be on the second third hour
it's a special guest do not tune into
mad maxworld.tv do not tune into Mad Max
no that's not a thing it's not a thing
it's just a fitness I don't know why
you're saying it I think I'm gonna have
to take you out in a straight jacket
because you keep naming things that
don't exist I was supposed to be shut
down I was supposed to be gone yeah well
you are because there's nothing there
I'm not on the number one you know live
show right now on YouTube and on uh
Rumble I mean you don't exist either no
no none of us exist have you seen Obama
and the rest I mean like and when I say
Obama I mean the new Obama the third
Obama Biden but also Obama they give
speeches now and have like 50 live
viewers really oh yeah it's pathetic
that sounds inflated well let's uh
yeah it probably is they're patting that
a little bit Yeah Frank lunson is stupid
tennis shoes and toupee uh I hear 50 or
50 okay there's 50 people they're like
uh it's just you yeah but this uh this
rug counts as two so uh we're going to
talk about this here exclusively on
Rumble usually this would be on mug Club
but you get to watch it this week so
Philly
some people call it Philadelphia I call
it Philly okay yeah uh they're gonna be
paying nearly 10 million dollars
to George Floyd protesters and I know
some of you what you're saying is going
what that's probably what some of you
responding uh so let me just uh play
this clip and then we'll go exclusively
to rumble because there's no way we can
touch this on on YouTube the city of
Philadelphia Philly for short they've
agreed to pay out 9.25 million I rounded
up to 10. to 342 protesters from the
George Floyd riots here's a clip we all
remember seeing these images in both May
and June of 2020. now the city has
agreed to pay a record 9.25 million
dollars to more than 300 protesters who
were injured by Philadelphia police
during demonstrations following the
murder of George Floyd
the absurdity of future millionaires
police brutality during a protest
against police brutality was not lost on
us
all right so uh this we're not going to
touch this with a 10-foot YouTube pole
download the rumble app right now just
go to ladder with credit.com or just hit
the button and go to rumble we are going
to continue with Alex Jones to discuss
this YouTube you have to do what I have
to do it which is piss off